my baby the fellas here with you tonight
he got a tux on y'all special night a
special night celebrating a special show
The Big Bang Theory after 12 seasons
Villere dear final episode may 16 on CBS
if we have damaging and embarrassing
information about someone should we keep
it to ourselves or expose them are you
going to be able to get through it I
might be cried out if that's possible
beep I if it's possible that it's
happened to me I have a little cried out
it's been an unbelievable couple days if
we're counting tissues after you guys
shot the finale where where are we oh
there are a lot of tissues it started
with reading that initial script and
then shooting it and then last night
shooting in front of the audience and
this morning with the hands that man
Chinese it's just been a beautiful
tribute to our show and I don't know I
just feel so grateful it's been a gift a
gift of 12 years you know how much I
love this show I love it so much I'm not
happy about any of this but as a viewer
will I be okay after the finale
I have to say this finale and I'm trying
I'm not biased I really because this has
been a stress for months about an Isis
actors the writers house it's gonna end
this is my legacy of this character on
and on it is the most beautiful finale I
have ever seen and I love finales either
that print all these amazing it is so
touching you're gonna cry but in the
sweetest way I don't know how to
describe it other than it's it's
absolutely the sweetest thing in the
world and Penny you're good with how she
ends up you're good thrilled I'm
thrilled with her her ending yet
beginning it's it's a beautiful there's
not anything catastrophic it's just
beautiful
I need the characters we're gonna live
on and you're in your mind's and in your
hearts and I think that's why it's so
special about it it's really touching I
know you love playing her and I know you
love this show so much so if they were
to come to
and say we think we still have stories
to tell about penny or Penny and Leonard
or whatever would you would you say okay
the only I think I've said this before
the only thing person I would say yes to
is Chuck Lorre so if Chuck came and said
let's do it I'd say yes other than that
I don't see a spinoff for myself but
Chuck always I don't like to say no to
Chuck so if he wanted it I meant can you
please ask Chuck please for me the
reruns will live on in our hearts